so last week we posted some photos on
our Facebook page showing a pile of
rubbish that was dumped near the kuiper
River most of you are pretty upset about
it and rightly so
it's disgusting and we all have to pay
to clean it up so we've recreated a
trailer load of rubbish similar to what
was found near the quiet boy River we've
got stuff in here like a baby car seat a
mattress a kitchen bench top and oven a
sneaker some polystyrene and to some
other bits and pieces similar to what
was found so we're going to take this
trailer load of rubbish through the
South Brook resource recovery park and
show you just how inexpensive it is to
deal with rubbish properly so we're at
our first stop and the recycling area we
were going to get rid of the oven items
my ovens can be dropped off for free at
the scrap metal and white wear section
cardboard and polystyrene can also be
recycled for free also shown in the
photos was a baby car seat you can now
bring these to the resale store and
recycle them for just $5 it's much
cheaper than taking it into Christchurch
to recycle and it doesn't matter what
condition it's in or even if it's
expired it's still just $5 if the
mattress and bench type were in good
condition these could also be dropped
off at the resale store
and so we'll take the rest of the stuff
through to the refuse area
[Music]
so total cost $36 really easy and most
of the stuff we brought along was able
to be recycled
[Music]